[Musique]
la haute-normandie vient d'être choisie
par les télécoms comme région pilote
pour essayer à nouveau système de
radiotéléphone marché très concurrentiel
où les appareils japonais se taillent
actuellement la part du lion
après une étude très précise sur le
développement potentiel de ce marché les
télécoms propose aujourd'hui à quelque
trente mille privilégié aux normands un
radio téléphone très bon marché que josé
alcala à expérimenter pour nous posséder
un téléphone dans sa voiture de type
portable comme celui ci est un
investissement coûteux 20 à 25 mille
francs l'appareil de plus la
communication est facturée 5 francs
l'unité dès le mois de juin prochain
les japonais vont investir le marché
européen en important des combinés
téléphoniques pour voitures au prix de
900 francs
c'est pour contrer cette invasion que
les télécommunications vont proposer aux
usagers un système imparable à la portée
de toutes les bourses
voici l'appareil proposé par les
télécommunications c'est un répartiteur
de fréquences son prix 250 francs il est
relié à l'auto radio sur la bande fm de
l'autre côté la prise de raccordement
n'importe quel combiné comme celui ci
fait la sphère l'antenne radio transmet
la fréquence jusqu'au relais hertziens
des télécoms de mesnil esnard lequel
renvoie la communication au central
téléphonique qui joue son rôle
normalement une seule petite restriction
les télécommunications ne pourront
attribuer que 20000 prise en
seine-maritime et 10000 dans le
département de l'eure alors vous savez
ce qu'il vous reste à faire car il n'y
en aura pas pour tout le monde
[Musique]